[Musique]
pour être un bon fossiles il faut être
mort et c'est bien la moindre des choses
tous les squelettes que vous voyez dans
les musées appartiennent à des animaux
qui sont morts se sont décomposées puis
dont le squelette a été fossilisé
au fil des millions d'années pourtant il
existe bel et bien une catégorie de
fossiles qui ont été faites durant le
vivant de l'animal et ses faux cils ce
sont les empreintes de pas les
empreintes de pas ont été faites par des
animaux vivant pendant qu'il marchait
alors que leur chère recouvrait encore
leur zone et sont par conséquent de
véritables fossiles vivants
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce petit cours de lecture
d'empreintes de pas où nous allons
aujourd'hui parler des empreintes de pas
de là et oli qui nous viennent de
tanzanie et qui datent de 3,6 millions
d'années alors ce que vous voyez en face
de vous et bien il s'agit en fait d'un
modèle 3d que j'ai réalisé par
photogrammétrie alors la photogrammétrie
c'est une technique qui permet de
reconstituer un modèle 3d à partir de
simples photos donc vous prenez
simplement en photo la surface que vous
voulez à partir de différents points de
vue et grâce à la parallaxe en fait le
logiciel va vous reconstruire votre
surface en trois dimensions alors que
peut-on voir sur ces empreintes fossiles
de la et au lit eh bien on peut voir
deux pistes deux pistes parallèles les
unes aux autres et la première chose
qu'on peut dire à partir de ces deux
pistes c'est qu'il n'y a que des
empreintes de pieds
c'est à dire que nous ne sommes pas face
à un animal quadrupèdes
regardez la première piste à une deux
trois empreintes de pieds mais pas
d'empreintes de mains et la deuxième
piste à une deux trois empreintes de
pieds mais pas d'empreintes de mains
donc nous sommes face à des animaux qui
sont bipèdes et pas n'importe quels
animaux bipèdes puisque si on regarde
attentivement ses empreintes
eh bien on va constater la présence d'un
pouce opposable
donc là si vous regardez bien cette
empreinte vous voyez ici le talon le
pack et d'orteils est ici un pouce très
nettement opposable ça se voit encore
mieux quand on utilise voyez quand on
utilise la vision sans textures donc
sans la texture on voit très très bien
le talon l'arc du pied et le pouce
opposable avec ici le reste des orteils
ici on voit le pouce opposable là et ici
on voit le pouce opposable là et sur les
grandes empreintes on peut aussi voir un
pouce opposable là un pouce opposable
ici et un pouce opposable là et quels
animaux sont des animaux avec des pouces
opposables aux pieds ce sont les sages
mesdames et messieurs ces empreintes de
pas de là et au lit sont des empreintes
qui ont été faits par des singes deep
end c'est à dire les tout premiers êtres
humains ou devrais-je plutôt dire des
hommes singes des australopithèques les
empreintes de pas fossiles de la et au
lit en plus donc d'être des fossiles
vivants sont aussi de parfaits chaînon
manquant puisqu'elle nous montre un
mélange de caractère à la fois humain la
bipédie et deux grands singes c'est à
dire le pouce opposable et c'est pour ça
que les empreintes de pas sont mes
fossiles favori et je vois ce que vous
êtes en train de vous dire vous êtes
probablement en train de vous dire que
les chimpanzés aussi sont capables de
marcher debout et qu'il pourrait tout
aussi bien s'agir d'empreintes de pas de
chimpanzés qui a marché de façon bipèdes
sur une très courte distance et je vous
répondrais que non car si vous regardez
attentivement ses empreintes de pas là
vous verrez que les pieds sont
parfaitement parallèles les uns aux
autres et non pas orientés vers
l'extérieur comme chez les chimpanzés
donc non il ne s'agit pas d'un grand
singe qui se serait mis à marcher droit
sur une courte distance
il s'agit bel et bien d'une piste où
l'on retrouve toutes les
caractéristiques d'une bipédie
obligatoire donc une bipédie humaine
mais avec un pouce opposable
et puisqu'on parle de ce pouce opposable
j'attire votre attention sur cette
empreinte là qui nous raconte une très
belle histoire
regardez cette empreinte il ne s'agit
pas d'une empreinte il s'agit en réalité
de deux empreintes
on voit ici la grande empreinte avec ici
les orteils et on redescend jusqu'au
talon et on voit ici une petite
empreinte à l'intérieur de la grande
empreinte avec son pouce opposable aussi
et ses propres orteils et son propre
salon et si on remonte la piste
eh bien on va retrouver la même chose
sur les autres empreintes une grande
empreinte et une plus petite empreinte
avec son talon
ses orteils et son gros orteil opposable
est pareil ici une petite empreinte à
l'intérieur de la grande empreinte avec
son pouce opposable
ici donc il n'y avait pas deux hommes
sages en train de parcourir la plaine de
tanzanie à ce moment là il y en avait en
réalité 3 et je m'autorise à croire
qu'il devait s'agir d' au moins un
adulte avec un enfant et peut-être même
un deuxième enfant ou une femelle adulte
qui marchaient derrière donc une petite
troupe d'australopithèques une petite
troupe d'une sage qui a parcouru la
plaine de tanzanie après que les cendres
volcaniques se soit fraîchement déposés
et est formé une boue dans laquelle ils
ont laissé leurs empreintes de pieds
qu'on peut encore admirer aujourd'hui
donc voilà c'est ça la magie des
fossiles vivants c'est ça la magie des
empreintes de pas ce ne sont pas des
empreintes d'animaux morts ce sont des
empreintes qui ont été faits par des
animaux vivants et ils nous racontent
bien plus de choses qu'on ne pourra
jamais en reconstituer à partir de
spéculations faites sur des ossements
voilà je vous remercie tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo et je vous dis à
très bientôt
[Musique]